>> Tucker Carlson announcing
plans to relaunch a show, this
time on Twitter.
Carlson made the announcement
in a video posted to Twitter.
>> You cannot have a free
society if people are not
allowed to say what they think
is true.
Speech is the fundamental
prerequisite for democracy,
that is why it is enshrined in
the first of our constitutional
amendments.
Amazingly, as of tonight, there
are not many platforms left
that allows free speech.
The last big one remaining in
the world, the only one's
Twitter where we are now.
>> My panel is back we also
have Los Angeles time --
and see any analyst Sarah
Fischer is joining us as well.
Sarah, he said, tucker went on
to say that he is going to put
his show on Twitter, what is a
Twitter TV show?
>> That's a great question I
think we're all dying to find
out.
Twitter has character limits
but when you subscribe to
Twitter blue, a subscription
service, you get a little bit
more space.
You can add a video to Twitter,
not a full hour length of video
though, Alison.
That's going to require a lot
of work on the back and.
I would imagine if you to do a
show it would be truncated, so
would not be that full hour
that he had it Faulk and you
might want to break it up.
Maybe you put out some segments
in different tweets, it said
right.
But as I understand right now,
they are going to have to race
to build that type of
functionality to get a full
hour long show there, although
they do have live functionality
so if you wanted to go live and
put a Twitter show up, I think
it would be possible.
>> Okay, that is interesting.
Tucker, your reporting, Sarah,
that tucker is accusing socks
of fraud and breach of
contract.
So how does he say that he
defrauded him?
>> Basically what he is saying
is that fox executives, what
sources tell me, is that fox's
chief legal and policy officer
Murdoch himself made promises
to Carlson saying that if you
handle your personal
communications will safeguarded,
to make sure it does not get
leaked.
And then now he is saying, look,
it has been leaked, it has been
reported on in the media, and
so you have a been broken a
verbal promise to me and that,
Carlson lawyers are saying is a
breach of his employment
contract because a breach of
the employer and a person who's
working for the company has
changed.
Of course that will be up to
court to decide whether or not
that will actually be
considered a breach of his
contract.
>> Okay, thank you sir very
much.
Let's bring in our panel now.
Josh, didn't they have to hand
it over in discovery?
Why is fox responsible for that?
They cannot responsibly for all
of this?
>> There is a number of
accusations in this letter to
fox, including that he claims
that one member of the fox
board told him that it was a
condition of the settlement
that they would fire him.
>> So dominion foxes both deny
that.
It does not make sense for
dominion to demand because
tucker is not even at the
center of their allegations,
but it's more about --
engineer and various other
people, and dominion does not
get any real financial gain
from them firing tucker Carlson,
so the first notes is just
because tucker Carlson has
accused vox of doing certain
things or something that he is
done all of them.
A lot of people have been
speculating about various
materials that have gotten to
the media since tucker
Carlson's firing, including
that text message in which he
is commenting on this riot band
saying that this is not how
white people fight and that fox
is concerned is that people are
going to find out that tucker
Goldman was racist and that is
why they fired him.
>> Breaking news.
>> The idea that fox is behind
those leaks, I do not find that
idea crazy, given the way that
foxes dealt with part of the
talent in the past but I think
this is all never get of the
fox --
tucker wants to be out there in
the arena, he is not allowed to
go and do another show unless
fox lets about the contracts of
our fox's been continuing to
pay him.
They can keep him under
contract until after the next
election.
>> I guess the bigger question
guys is what does this mean for
the world?
What does this mean for the
world?
If he does not have his
powerful platform on fox, which
is a powerful platform, and it
is on Twitter, does that
suddenly reduces power?
>> I think is power has been so
greatly reduced.
They say they even have a
Twitter show, we are all asking
what that means because it is
not a thing.
I uploaded videos of my dog, my
dog does not have a Twitter
show.
And so, I think that this is a
man who has been embarrassed
publicly, has lost his job
publicly, this feels like a
last gasp in the same way that
Elon Musk owning Twitter feels
like a last gasp of trying to
be relevant.
It is a dying social network,
nobody knows who is verified,
people are very fight now
unhinged.
I do not see what he gets out
of this.
The audience is largely older
and does not know how to have
to factor verification,
especially not using their
phone.
So, I do not see this as some
great come back I see this as
diminishing returns in every
way.
>> That's interesting, I would
also caution that reports of
his demise may be premature
because tucker, I think, does
have a grip on a large portion
of America and is a, if you
read the comments under his
announcement, people are like I
can't wait.
The hail was a fox, they are
ready to go wherever you're
going.
>> The question about power, we
first need to define how we are
to fighting power.
Yes, he lost the power from
being on fox, but what other
power does he still have and
how is he going to use that
power because, as we saw, fox
was just one aspect of his
influence.
He is influenced in a lot of
different areas in terms of
everyday life and while he may
not have the same audiences on
Twitter, he may not need to
have the same size death
assimilate or greater impact.
Power is not simply about
Twitter followers or simply
being on television, power is
what is happening --
>> Thank you for that, I like
that.
>> One of the ways that he had
power is that he did have the
ear, and in fact often more
than the ear of some
politicians like Kevin
Mccarthy.
Kind Mccarthy to hand over the
tapes from January 6th, he was
influential in Republican
political circles.
It will be still have?
That >> That influence still
exists, will it wane a little
bit we will have to see.
If you look at somebody like
Ron Desantis is easily able to
get the message out, whatever
that message of the week was,
they put on the placards on the
front of those podiums.
So yes that is going to change
a little bit, do not
necessarily dismiss Twitter
right away, certainly he is
probably going to deal with the
fact that a large portion of
that 3.6 million who are tuning
in do not have the two-factor
authentication, do not actually
know where they can even
download Twitter from.
But, there is also the
potential for new audiences.
I made the comparison to
somebody who says that they are
a member or supporter of
planned parenthood versus a
member or supporter of the NRA.
Even though they have not given
any money or 8 to 10 or 20
years.
It is that type of synthetic
organization of people who
support someone, and many of
them had been getting that
information in a digital
landscape via Facebook, via
Twitter, so I just think that
there is the opportunity even
if you're not necessarily
watching him live, during a
Twitter live for those clips to
be recorded, to be dispersed
through YouTube, through a vast
multitude of increasingly
fractured but also growing
digital spaces.
>> Sarah, that there was
another plot twist about all of
this and that is what Elon Musk
had to say about it.
He said, I also want to be
clear, this was after tucker's
statement, that we have not
signed a deal of any kind
whatsoever.
Tucker is subjected to the same
rules and rewards of all
content creators.
That means inscriptions,
advertising revenue, shares,
which is a function of how many
people subscribe and the
advertising abuse associated
with the content.
I hope many others,
particularly from the left,
also choose to --
be content creators on this
platform.
I think that is a strange
announcement, announcing that
you just landed your biggest
star.
>> Right, expect him to welcome
tucker with open, arms and wait
a, minute you're subject of the
same rules as everyone else,
we're gonna fact-check you with
community notes, just like
everyone else.
Look, Elon Musk has a tough job
on his hands.
He's got to bring advertisers
back, make sure users stay on
the platform.
And he knows by being on a
polarizing figure like tucker
Carlson, even if he's really
popular on the, right that
could jeopardize his ability to
continue to grow the business.
So, that's why I think you seem
responding in a different
manner, saying look, I think
it's great that you're here but
we're not going to give you
special treatment just cause
you're doing this show with us.
The last thing I'd say, Alisyn,
is that tucker is going to
explore other options.
I don't expect the Twitter
thing to be the only thing he
does.
Newsmax Chris rodeos said we
could still welcome a show with
Carlson.
So, male trial the Twitter
thing.
I think he likes the zeitgeist